[Música]
y
el escritor británico de origen indio
salman rushdie sigue hospitalizado pero
ya sin respiración asistida un día
después del ataque con cuchillo del que
fue víctima en el estado de nueva york
el acusado un joven de 24 años se
declaró inocente
rusia asegura controlar una nueva ciudad
ucraniana a las afueras de donges que en
la región del donbass desde el gobierno
de quiebra afirma que todavía hay en
marcha una feroz batalla
siete personas resultaron heridas
después de que alguien disparara contra
un autobús en la ciudad vieja de
jerusalén en las primeras horas del
domingo este suceso llega después de 10
detenciones entre israel y los
territorios palestinos
actualizamos a las noticias en la
pantalla de france 24 gracias por
continuar con nosotros yo soy juan
pupiales el escritor salman rushdie
permanece en un hospital del noroeste
del estado de pensilvania y este sábado
presentó una mejoría después de que se
le retirara la respiración asistida
wright y sufrió este viernes un violento
ataque en un evento literario el agresor
tiene 24 años y se declaró inocente hoy
ante la justicia ampliamos en el
siguiente informe de samuel salgado
este es el momento exacto del ataque al
escritor británico de origen indio
cuando se preparaba para una conferencia
en el estado de nueva york la policía
pudo someter al agresor de inmediato a
quien identificaron con el nombre deja
de matar quien este sábado se declaró
inocente de intento asesinato en segundo
grado y otros cargos a los que se le
acusa la próxima cita con la justicia
será el 19 de agosto mientras tanto
deberá permanecer en prisión preventiva
tras el ataque el escritor salman
rushdie sigue luchando por su vida en un
hospital del noroeste del estado de
pensilvania al que fue trasladado en un
helicóptero y remitido a cirugía
es un individuo que ha pasado décadas
diciendo la verdad al poder
alguien que ha estado ahí afuera sin
miedo a pesar de las amenazas que lo han
perseguido durante toda su vida
rossi recibió tres puñaladas en el
cuello y cuatro en el estómago su agente
literario andrew wylie dijo que uno de
los brazos del escritor está gravemente
afectado así como su hígado y su ojo
luego de permanecer un día con
respiración asistida este sábado la
condición médica de rossi presentó
avances y ya no necesito más conexión a
un ventilador su obra literaria le causó
enemigos en el campo religioso en
1989 irán ordenó la muerte de rost y al
acusarlo de blasfemia
en ucrania dos nuevos barcos con granos
partieron desde el mar negro ellas son
16 los navíos que han salido del país
como parte de un acuerdo respaldado por
naciones unidas- las de ese sábado son
dos embarcaciones con banderas de
barbados y de islas marshall que portan
12.000 toneladas de maíz y 3000 de
semillas de girasol ambos partieron
rumbo a turquía país que firmó este
acuerdo con ucrania y rusia en medio de
una escasez de esos suministros a nivel
mundial sobre todo en naciones en vías
de desarrollo
mientras tanto hay versiones encontradas
sobre la situación de peces que una
pequeña población a las afueras de la
provincia de donges que en la región del
donbass mientras la rusia asegura que
tiene el control total de esta localidad
el gobierno ucraniano afirma que allí
sigue librándose y feroces combates por
otro lado el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski pidió a europa que
los ciudadanos rusos no puedan cruzar la
frontera hacia hacia el bloque
comunitario andrés granadillo con los
detalles
cae otro objetivo en la región de done
jets eso fue lo que reportó el
ministerio de defensa ruso que afirma
haber tomado el control de la localidad
de pesca el portavoz del ministerio de
defensa de rusia ígor konashénkov dijo
que
como resultado del avance las fuerzas
rusas y prorrusas esto en la república
popular de unesco ha sido completamente
liberada cerca de klamath ox en la
república popular de on esq un sistema
de cohetes y mar y un depósito con
municiones fueron destruidos
vamos de acá más precisamente cohetes
rusos alcanzaron crema torch el viernes
en la noche causando la muerte a tres
personas y dejando 11 heridos
alina asegura haber sobrevivido por
estar guarecida en su casa
es bueno si estuviéramos en la calle no
estoy segura de que pudiéramos hablar
con usted ahora todos los elementos de
los proyectiles están en el patio o el
hecho de que estuviéramos dentro de la
casa no usar su visto sólo esto
tras los ataques que no cesan y la
guerra que ya completa casi seis meses
el presidente volodymyr selenski insiste
en el bloqueo a rusia ya sus ciudadanos
bowers malla mudéjar angels shorts y
esquí en primer lugar se debe garantizar
que los asesinos rusos y los cómplices
del terrorismo de estado no puedan usar
las visas seng y en segundo lugar la
idea de europa en sí mismas no puede
destruirse nuestros valores europeos
comunes no pueden destruirse lo que
significa que no podemos convertir a
europa en un supermercado donde no
importa quién venga lo único que importa
es que se paguen las compresión marc no
ni no pulgar entretanto moscú advirtió a
washington que si eeuu convierte en ley
la propuesta de proyecto presentado en
la cámara de representantes que pide
declarar a rusia como un estado
patrocinador del terrorismo las
relaciones bilaterales se destruirían
por completo seguimos hablando de ese
tema porque jóvenes rusos que no quieren
combatir en ucrania han huido a moldavia
nuestra enviada especial sobre el
terreno del bonet habló con alguno ellos
vlada empezado una nueva vida llegó hace
dos meses aquí sin out donde ha
encontrado un trabajo temporal en un
polígono industrial ha dejado a las
familias y sus sueños de futuro forma
parte de los jóvenes que no quieren
combatir en la guerra más grande nuestra
veo en este año iba a acabar la
universidad de quería montar mi propio
negocio de bicicletas llegó una carta a
casa de mis padres pidiendo que acudiera
a una oficina de registro militar decidí
ir a moldavia
con lo que cobra la edad para pagar una
pequeña habitación en un apartamento
compartido nos sale mucho de casa le
pese a su decisión de haber ido pero el
que asiste apoya al bando ruso en la
guerra y si escala tendrá que luchar
contra el cráneo
su abuelo luchó con el ejército
soviético contra los nazis en la segunda
guerra mundial ahora es diferente
por orden de rusia el gobierno nos está
diciendo que tenemos que prepararnos que
el otro lado de la frontera hay un
régimen nazi que quiere desestabilizar
la región están metiendo miedo a la
gente todo es mentira
andrew haya dejado todas las cosas en su
piso de estudiante de moscú pero se ha
traído su mesa de mezclas no podría
vivir sin sus sesiones de música
experimental llegó hace unos días y se
está quedando en casa de unos amigos en
chisinau
no podía estar más tiempo en moscú la
situación es insoportable cada día se
ven más pintadas en los muros la letra
zeta que significa apoyo a la guerra hay
una fuerte presencia policial en las
calles ya ni siquiera podemos usar las
redes vpn seguras para navegar en
internet no hay libertad de opinión y
han aumentado las redadas a activistas
estudiando primero con andrew no puede
visitar a su familia en tiráspol porque
el ejército de transnistria lo está
buscando para que se enrolen el servicio
mental
andray blatche pertenecen a una minoría
silenciada rusa sus testimonios sirven
para dar luz y no estigmatizar a una
población a la que no se ha preguntado
si quiere la guerra
vamos a francia porque este país
enfrenta una sequía de proporciones
históricas en medio de las altas
temperaturas que azotan a europa pese a
que el uso del agua se encuentra
restringido en más de 90 regiones en
lyon muchos dueños de lavadero de autos
continúan operando con normalidad
argumentan que no pueden detener sus
negocios por otro lado bomberos de
países vecinos como alemania y grecia
llegaron para ayudar a combatir los
incendios que han afectado miles de
hectáreas de bosque
de europa vamos a medio oriente siete
personas resultaron heridas después de
que un ataque contra un bus en la ciudad
vieja de jerusalén en las primeras horas
del domingo el hecho ocurrió cerca del
muro de las lamentaciones un lugar de
oración de mayor importancia para los
judíos ahora avanza un operativo para
encontrar al autor este suceso llega
después de 10 versiones entre israel y
los territorios palestinos con 13 días
de enfrentamientos con la franja de gaza
que dejaron al menos 49 palestinos
muertos a la 1 y 24 recibimos la llamada
de que un terrorista estaba disparando
en masa en el muro de los lamentos en
jerusalén cuando llegamos a la escena
había algunas personas tendidas en el
suelo tres de ellas estaban en estado
crítico y otros pocos se resultaron
levemente heridos había un bebé que
sacamos del camino del peligro y todos
fueron trasladados al hospital para su
cuidado
me detuve en la estación del autobús de
la tumba de david en ese momento
comienzan los disparos veo caer dos
personas afuera dos adentro estaban
sangrando y todos entraron en pánico
se cumplen 75 años de la partición entre
india y pakistán en este último país
miles de personas se congregaron en la
ciudad de labor acompañando al ex primer
ministro y run can para conmemorar la
fecha el evento y terminó haciendo una
especie de acto político en el que can
hizo un llamado a buscar la verdadera
libertad fue en agosto de 1947 cuando
terminó el mandato británico que india
de mayoría hindú y pakistán de mayoría
musulmana proclamaron su independencia
desde entonces ambas naciones han
peleado tres guerras en medio de
millones de familias que quedaron
separadas por esta partición
alí hasan vaca y nació en 1946 tan solo
un año antes de la partición de india y
pakistán tras su independencia de reino
unido su familia era una de las millones
de familias musulmanas que había en
india pero tras la creación de pakistán
tuvo que irse con sus abuelos de loba
delhi dejando atrás por décadas a parte
de sus familiares por fase 7 india en
2014 mi madre estaba enferma en ese
momento fui a conocerla y a mi madre
después de mucho tiempo estaba postrada
en la cama la llevé al hospital y luego
tuve 15 o 16 días con ella muy bien pero
cuando me fui a la india nunca imaginé
que no la volvería a ver cualquier beba
se sala la división de pakistán e india
sigue presente para muchos 75 años
después debido a su gran dureza la
independencia de indias se dio en un
contexto de enfrentamiento entre los
diferentes grupos religiosos y étnicos
de esta nación una tensión que degeneró
en la ruptura del territorio en tres
partes la actual india de mayoría hindú
pakistán de mayoría musulmana y pakistán
oriental actualmente conocido como bando
también de mayoría musulmana
una decisión que hizo que hasta 15
millones de personas tuvieran que
desplazarse de sus hogares para llegar
al país que reconocía a su religión como
mayoritaria un desastre humanitario que
ocasionó entre 1 y 3 millones de muertos
por hambre y violencia y que separan en
la actualidad a muchas familias
raros hay miles de familias así algunas
impulsadas y otras en más lugares
tartaglina sus cartillas sienten un
dolor intenso por la aportación y su
corazón lo soporta como nosotros en
total listas los gobiernos de ambas
naciones deberían escuchar las quejas de
sus ciudadanos aunque un dolor difícil
de sanar ya que la mala relación actual
entre india y pakistán que se han
enfrentado en cuatro guerras el siglo
pasado ha contribuido a profundizar la
división
en noticias de américa latina' en
colombia la vicepresidenta francia
márquez se posicionó de manera simbólica
en una ceremonia con comunidades
indígenas y afro en su tierra natal
márquez es la primera mujer afro en
llegar a la vicepresidencia en este país
sudamericano como fórmula del presidente
gustavo petro marqués estuvo en suárez
un municipio del departamento del cauca
al suroeste de colombia en una región
lastrada por el conflicto armado y los
cultivos ilícitos la vicepresidenta se
comprometido con la denominada paz total
bandera de la nueva administración
y terminamos también hablando de
colombia en medellín conocida como la
ciudad de la eterna primavera se lleva a
cabo por estos días el festival de las
flores una de las ferias más populares
de este país nuestra periodista manuel
acá no se encuentra en este evento y nos
cuenta acerca de su importancia para la
cultura de esta nación
estamos en santa elena a pocos
kilómetros de la capital antioqueña
medellín al oeste del territorio
colombiano aquí es el corazón de la
feria de las flores una de las
festividades más importantes de colombia
que es patrimonio de la nación estamos
en donde la familia londoño una familia
de silleteros de larga tradición que ha
pasado durante generación y generación
en la labor de hacer estas silletas que
vemos acá puede empezar entre 30 y 120
kilogramos o incluso más y estos
participan en diferentes categorías que
pueden ir desde artísticas hasta
tradicionales y acá en este caso tengo a
jonathan que participa en la categoría
emblemática jonathan yo quería
preguntarle qué es tan importante esta
tradición para usted y para toda su
familia bueno realmente esa tradición
para nosotros significa mucho porque
recordar que la feria de las flores y
las silletas no nacieron como un evento
no nacieron como una fiesta que trae
personas de todo el mundo sino que esto
nació como la forma en la que nuestros
abuelos nuestros
vendían las flores de forma en la que
ellos cultivaban para traer la comida a
sus casas y sacar sus familias adelante
descargar una silleta que como bien lo
decías 30 50 80 hasta 120 kilos
significa también cargar esa tradición y
sobre todo homenajear ese trabajo duro
que ellos hicieron
estas galletas saldrán de acá hacia
beijing en donde el lunes se dará el
desfile tradicional en donde saldrán
muchos nuevos ganadores más de 500
silleteros esperan con ansias este
momento después de dos años de pandemia
reencontrarse con la gente y saber quién
va a ser el ganador de esta edición de
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
en la pantalla de france 24 pero
quédense en nuestra señal y también
visiten nuestro sitio web
france24 punto com
[Música]